et bien qu est-ce que c'est mon dieu
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un schmilblick
vous le savez depuis hier soir depuis
que notre ami pierre dac nous en a donné
une définition assez confuse d'ailleurs
c'est à dire un objet un objet dont vous
devez trouver ou l'utilisation ou le nom
très exact soit ce schmilblick et bien
regardez le à nouveau je crois que c'est
quand même très important c'est
l'essentiel du jeu moi je vous dit
bonsoir bien sûr amis de toute la france
et ami de strasbourg plus
particulièrement amis de strasbourg vous
allez voir quelques instants pourquoi du
moins je l'espère et revenons sur ce
schmilblick
ce schmilblick vous l'avez sûrement vu
un jour ou l'autre
peut-être pas celui là d'ailleurs mais
un autre exactement pareil certains le
voient souvent et j'ajouterais
d'ailleurs que d'autres le voient tous
les jours c'est la station régionale de
lille qui l'a choisi pour la soumettre
le soumettre vous exactement ce
schmilblick
ce nom dont vous allez j'espère devenir
très familier à la sagacité des
téléspectateurs de la france entière et
aujourd'hui ce sont les téléspectateurs
de strasbourg qui vont pouvoir tenter
leur chance alors j'espère que nous
avons strasbourg c'est formidable ce
merveilleux et quelques instants eh bien
ils étaient schmilblick et le manège
existe alors pour encourager nos avis de
strasbourg si vous le permettez je vais
dès maintenant à la seconde même et
c'est un des principes importants du jeu
mettre de l'argent dans la cagnotte du
schmilblick
regardez ce merveilleux petit oreilles
la progression est toujours 200 francs
ce sera le seul donc je ferai d'ailleurs
au schmilblick les autres ce sera grâce
à vous que ils vont venir
alors maintenant il y à 100 francs dans
la cagnotte qu'est ce que ce schmilblick
avoue strasbourg avoue gérard brianti et
nous sommes à strasbourg effectivement
la nuit commence à tomber sur la ville
nous sommes très exactement devant la
maison de l'horreur tf il y à des
spectateurs en face de moi et il ya des
candidats à ma droite 19 candidats très
exactement je pense qu'il eût que s'il
en vient d'autres en cours d'émission
nous essaierons de les faire passer ce
sera bien sûr une question de temps je
précise que jacques solness et dans le
public il a préféré
en coulisses ce soir alors si vous
voulez bien nous allons tout de suite
appelé le premier candidat d'accord ah
oui mais attendez attendez attendez
combien il y a deux candidats d'inscrits
dis-je
et maintenant nous allons voir dans quel
ordre les candidats vont être appelés à
donner et surtout l'honneur au premier
la première définition du schmilblick
alors attention monsieur ou madame qui
allait être la première où le premier à
nous donner cette définition c'est le
départ du jeu on a tous un peu le coeur
qui bat vous allez me poser une question
est ce que par exemple public se mange
ça sert à manger enfin voyez ce que je
veux dire quelque chose d'aussi vague
si je vous réponds oui et seulement si
je vous réponds oui vous avez le droit
de donner le nom d'un schmilblick celui
que vous croyez être le bon et dans ce
cas ci c'est vrai vous emporter le total
du montant qui n'est pas gros par contre
si je vous dis non je dis au revoir
merci à la prochaine fois voilà c'est
clair alors attention pour 12 minutes
maintenant
chronomètre pour la première fois le jeu
du schmilblick part sur les antennes de
l'ortm et c'est le candidat numéro
numéro numéro 11 je crois qui a
l'honneur d'ouvrir le feu avoue
strasbourg avoue qu'en dit la numéro ces
voix le candidat numéro 11 qui a gravi
les trois marches qui permet d'arriver
jusqu'au micro monsieur votre nom le
provost gérard strasbourg votre question
est ce que le public veut servir un
sportif le schmilblick ne peut pas
servir un sportif mais la première
question est déjà embarrassante et spa
jean-marc je crois que il y a un rapport
mais alors vraiment très très très très
lointain avec le sport mais ça ne peut
pas servir un sportif par conséquent
monsieur je suis obligé de vous dire
merci au deuxième candidat le candidat
numéro 1 1 as le large et du verre c'est
une candidate d'ailleurs qui arrive
bonjour madame mademoiselle gênant est
ce que le jury spécialisé en cui dans la
cuisine répété moi comment vous dites le
mot chemise alizée schmilblick
ah ça ira mieux en alsace est presque à
un nom du cru est ce que ça peut servir
à dans la cuisse dans la cuisine
absolument pas mademoiselle je suis
désolé non merci
troisième candidat le numéro 19
candidat suivant il arrive que monsieur
roll strasbourg france et strasbourg est
ce que le schmilblick
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser le
schmilblick couramment oui je crois
qu'on peut utiliser le schmilblick
couramment dans la mesure où vous avez
besoin d schmilblick
sinon je ne pense pas que vous quel est
votre profession monsieur vous avez
votre profil étudiant non alors vous
n'utilisez pas le schmilblick couramment
je suis désolé pour vous et je suis
encore plus désolé pour la cagnotte du
schmilblick
rien dans la cagnotte le candidat numéro
10 maintenant le candidat numéro 10 quel
âge as-tu 13 ans mais il me semblait que
dans ce jour une fabrique à partir de la
majorité sur toile avec toi tu peux nous
a montré c'est c'est une vérité
l'autorisation oui tu peux jouer alors
ton nom de toute façon fischer thierry
sheedy kent la question est ce que je
suis
link peut s'employer une maison leur
public peut pas employer dans une maison
donne moi ton prénom mon lapin thierry
thierry vient terry n'ont franchement
pas mais je pense qu'on va demander à
notre réalisateur de remontrer une fois
le schmilblick regarde le bien et si tu
as déjà vu ça dans ta maison dans la
maison d'un thé petits camarades alors
tu viendras nous le dit regarde non
voilà le schmilblick à nouveau sur les
écrans alors que nous appelons
maintenant le concurrent numéro 10
le concurrent numéro 10 s'est souvenu
sur votre est grand pour un petit peu
thiery voilà concurrent numéro 10 ce
monsieur je disais que c'était toujours
sur vos écrans le numéro à droite de
l'écran qui est appelé en premier
klein daniel strasbourg est ce que le
schmilblick se rencontrent sur le bord
des routes
le schmilblick que ne se rencontrent pas
sur le bord des routes ou alors il
faudrait une circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles je crois
évidemment si je précisais la situation
exceptionnelle qui pourrait faire que la
chine bric se rencontrent au bord des
routes ça vous mettrait sur la voie
mais là ça nécessite une petite seconde
de réflexion si vous permettez à vos
réponses daniel je vais prendre conseils
de jean marc alors nous montrons
schmilblick à l'image
je reviens à strasbourg après ce petit
temps de réflexion puisque c'est la
première question qui nous a mis un peu
en difficulté ce qui prouve qu'elle
était très précise alors nous vous
autorisons à nous donner le nom d'un
schmilblick à quoi pensez-vous
je pensais ça n'est pas cela je suis
désolé pour vous mais néanmoins puisque
vous avez posé une question positive se
voir le plaisir de m si vous le
permettez 100 francs de plus dans la
cagnotte est maintenant le schmilblick
pour 200 francs et nous passons
maintenant aux candidats aux concurrents
strasbourgeois où ça a l'air de très
bien se passer numéro 7 pour l'énergie
le père strasbourg est ce que le
schmilblick sa chaîne dans un évident
saveur à ce jeu c'est à dire que non je
ne crois pas freire qui connaît là je me
levais je veux pas du tout comment vous
restez ça dans un débit de tabac mais
par curiosité à quoi pensiez-vous une
cigarette
non non ce n'est pas cela monsieur en
tous les cas et bien en votre honneur
nous enfume brune tout à l'heure bonsoir
monsieur aux concurrents suivants le
numéro six mois et sportive qu'est ce
que je peux me servir un schmilblick
nous avait pas dit votre nom monsieur
d'abord monsieur corollaire auray
morbihan
quel est votre prénom jacky la bretagne
en alsace et quel est le sport que vous
pratiquez monsieur bah tout un peu de
tout non je ne crois pas que voulez vous
ayez jamais eu l'occasion de pratiquer
un sport avec le schmilblick vous savez
je ne crois pas merci monsieur
excusez-nous est encore à bientôt
numéro 4 maintenant monsieur votre nom
de bord genève hélène gerhards de
schiltigheim
est-ce que vous monsieur guy lux vous
servez du schmilblick assez amusant
écoutez je n'ai pas l'impression gésiers
tout à l'heure ayant découvert le nom du
schmilblick qui avait été tenu secret
par ceux qui l'ont découvert
jusqu'à la dernière seconde j'essayais
de me souvenir si j'avais pu me servir
d'un schmilblik ou si j'en avais
rencontré honnêtement j'en ai peut-être
rencontrer un comme je l'aï dit au début
d'ailleurs de cette émission on en a
peut-être tous vu à et certains en voit
tous les jours mais moi personnellement
je vous dis jamais et vous sûrement pas
à moins que vous ne donniez votre métier
et votre métier monsieur schnoebelen
agents commencent à jean-louis un genre
alors tf1 en relation me rend pas à la
rtf pas de public
merci monsieur d'être venu nous voir
qu'en dit la numéro 12 le numéro suivant
monsieur ou madame c'est monsieur
partait vraiment strasbourg est ce que
le schmilblick se trouve dans les champs
le schmilblick ne se trouve pas dans les
champs enfin je pense que quand vous
parlez h de chant par les ca ch amps
n'est ce pas très bien non monsieur
n'ont absolument pas désolé un autre le
candidat numéro 12 c'est une candidate
de strasbourg alors on empêcher le
schmilblick se met autour du cou à la
coquetterie féminine voyez eh bien
madame regarder à nouveau ce schmilblick
là et dites moi si vous pouvez vous
mettre ça autour du cou c'est quand même
surprenant
vous avez un sens de la coquetterie à
c'est assez curieux madame non je ne
vois pas du tout la schmilblick dont il
est question autour de votre cou madame
j'en suis désolé pour vous et c'est
dommage parce qu'il faut maintenant 200
francs au concurrent numéro 18 qui est
une concurrente madame ou mademoiselle
madame aubry dit est ce que je pourrais
soulevé le schmilblick à question en
plein d'astuces plein d'astuces vous
permettez on va remontrer le schmilblick
et je vais finalement posé cette
question parce que c'est une question de
poids finalement combien pèse la
schmilblick ça je n'ignore je pose donc
question de jean-marc
méditons effectivement vous pourriez
soulevé le schmilblick
alors vous êtes autorisé maintenant à
préciser le nom des schmilblick auquel
vous pensez et immédiatement jeu mais
sans prendre pied dans la cagnotte si
vous répondez bien vous en planter 300
francs eh bien je pense à une borne
kilométrique
pourquoi vous avez l'habitude de porter
des patches et l'amérique assez pas un
canular ou déplacer des kilomètres
français ça les passages sur madmoizelle
merci à tous les codes votre charmant
sourire et de votre intervention
concurrentes ou concurrents numéro 10
est monsieur henri jean pierre de
strasbourg est ce que le schmilblick et
vivant non le schmilblick n'est pas
vivant je suis désolé jean pierre à
bientôt concurrent numéro 16
c'est encore un jeune homme est ce que
le schmilblick sert à travailler
oui monsieur oui le schmilblick sert à
travailler
c'est un instrument de travail et
j'aimerais que immédiatement alors que
on me fait signe en régie faut que je
m'habitue à ce petit voyez moi je suis
pas généreux je veux pas mettre d'argent
dans la cagnotte
j'avais sans prendre plus maintenant il
ya 400 francs après pensez vous monsieur
un morceau de craie ah oui effectivement
on va revoir le schmilblick une fois
s'il vous plaît justement on pourrait
penser que c'est un morceau de craie
montrer le oui non monsieur ce n'est pas
cela désolé en tous les cas vous avez
fait monter la cagnotte des chemises dit
merci aux concurrents suivants 15 petit
jean marc de strasbourg est ce que le
public est-il conducteur du courant
électrique
petit jean marc de strasbourg le
schmilblick n'a rien à voir avec le
courant électrique
je suis désolé concurrent numéro 14 une
très jeune concurrente argué lire
strasbourg elle que le schmilblick sert
aux menuisiers ce héros menuisier aux
menuisiers non mademoiselle
mais big ne sert absolument pas aux
menuisiers concurrents aux concurrentes
numéro il est encore très peu de
concurrence je crois qu'ils luxe
approché bien gardé les un tout petit
peu plus longtemps puisque nous sommes
tellement heureux de retrouver nos amis
geeks attendait monsieur n'a pas entendu
votre nom je crois frei ce monsieur
price est ce que le schmilblick est un
monument
ah non monsieur non non vraiment pas un
monument effectivement d'ailleurs
regardez le à nouveau monsieur fraysse
regardez le schmilblick
on pouvait penser que c'était à bout de
cigarettes que ça pouvait être en effet
une borne kilométrique mais comme
monument c'est assez rudimentaire ça
n'est pas un monument monsieur fraysse
et nous passons aux concurrents suivants
qui est également un très jeune
concurrent quand tu appelles tu mets
rossana patrick et puis de strasbourg
est ce que le schmilblick le schmiblick
sert aux médecins non non non non petit
ami non le smilblick ne sert pas du tout
aux médecins des spas jean-marc je ne
crois vraiment pas que jamais un médecin
se soit servi de shilvi courageux même
très précis je crois que jamais un
médecin ne s'est jamais servi d'un
schmilblick
merci d'être venus et le concurrent sud
ans et sa maman je crois à dont il était
avec sa maman c'est pour ça qu'il avait
la période j'ai demandé à maman de lui
son jeune âge
pourtant je vois que non je crois que
l'amendement n'est pas du tout
intervenus ma jambe cette aventure où
jean marc est déjà parti vous savez il
est pareil on m'a dit qu'il n'y a plus
que trois concurrents non mais nous
avons quelques concurrents
supplémentaires en avons quatre ou cinq
ans au lieu de montrer monsieur guy lux
feriez mieux de montrer le schmilblick
mon cher ami je n'ai rien à ce public
voilà très bien ah et bien en tous les
cas gérard brianti désolé les trois
derniers concurrents ne pourront même
pas passé vous savez que nous sommes
dans un carcan horaire extrêmement
précis et nous n'avons que 12 minutes il
est quand même passé pas mal de
concurrents je crois que nous pouvons
résumer rapidement que ce n'est ni un
monument ni un bout de cigarettes que ça
ne sert pas docteur que ça ne sert pas
au sportif
d'ailleurs de toute façon demain au
début de l'émission ce sera notre
premier souci de bien résumé tout cela
vous savez que ce soir grâce à quatre
interventions brillante notre
schmilblick est arrivé à 400 francs
d'ailleurs nous allons montrer à nouveau
le schmilblick et le prix qu'il a
atteint 400 francs vous avez compris le
principe alors extrêmement simple
biblique de ce je vous posais une
question si elle est bonne je vous
autorise à donner le nom d'un
schmilblick et si vous donnez le
véritable nom vous emporter le montant
de la cagnotte
demain je crois jean-marc que nous
jouons avec nos amis de bordeaux et bien
rendez vous à bordeaux c'est merveilleux
nous faisons tous les soirs à tour de
france le schmilblick est parti pour un
tour de france j'ai l'impression qu'il
risque de tenir longtemps
commencez vous même à bien surveiller
cette image sur laquelle nous allons
nous séparer et demain à bordeaux je
suis sûr que déjà le problème va se
resserrer
merci de votre attention merci l'alsace
bonsoir strasbourg bonsoir la france à
demain avec notre schmilblick 400 francs
et bonne chance à tous
c'est demain à 18h20 je vous le rappelle
que nous retrouverons guy lux et les
nouveaux jets le schmilblick
à présent voici à nouveau numéro du
magazine féminin de maïté ses verriers
de sannois